guillaume la scuderia ce comment peut-on
envisager la prise de kiev comment peut-
être prises une ville aussi importante
déjà prendre une ville ça prend du temps
parce que il faut déjà sécuriser les
accès et les bloquer on n'est pas le
siège d'une ville comme ça de manière
aussi évidente surtout une ville comme
kiev qui est une ville un petit peu
tentaculaire alors c'est quand même plus
de trois millions d'habitants c'est une
espace et en plus elle est coupée par un
fleuve donc ça le niais pour ça rend pas
les choses beaucoup plus simples donc il
va falloir du temps voir aussi un gros
dispositif c'est à dire qu'il faut
amener des hommes du matériel du soutien
du ravitaillement toutes les choses qui
nécessitent de planifier prendre du
temps et puis le troisième point c'est
un assaut contre une ville c'est
extrêmement chronophage mais c'est aussi
coûteux en vies humaines
bien évidemment et en matériel et puis
en tant faut imaginer que on a besoin
d'à peu près une armée qui avance bien
dans une ville pour avance à peu près
d'un kilomètre par jour donc c'est à
dire que un siège et a fortiori un siège
dans une ville qui va se défendre cela
prend du temps et cela coûtera des
pertes humaines du niveau catastrophique
merci beaucoup gamescom jarraya semaine